Jurassic Park means so much to so many
people in this movie recaptures so much
of that spirit and the the joy and the
Wonder and the thrills of the first
movie what elements in this film do you
think how does it recapture it in your
mind how does it do that what are the
elements inside of the Jurassic world um
well i mean i think i think that uh i
mean Jurassic Park for me I'll start
there III saw the movie when I was 12
years old in the theaters opening
weekend and I was super interested in in
movies and storytelling and cinema I was
kind of one of those like I was a young
sort of dorkiest in a file and um for
the movies at least that my parents
would let me watch uh and I remember
seeing that film and it was almost like
an aspiring painter seeing the Sistine
Chapel for the first time you know it's
it was an unbelievable feat of of
masterful storytelling and breakthrough
technology and kind of the combination
of that and and and what what got
created is you know a movie that's
ultimately cinematic history Jurassic
Park and so with this movie with
Jurassic world I mean it's been 22 years
since the first film and I think what's
so cool about it is it's the wish
fulfillment
you know it's John Hammonds dream come
to life it's a fully operational theme
park but it's also very realistic
because if there was a theme park where
the attractions were dinosaurs that have
been around for a decade or so I mean
would people really be into dinosaurs
you know would their interests be able
to be sustained for that long and so the
premise of this story is that in order
to keep visitors coming to the island
and coming to the park we need to create
a dinosaur that's going to capture their
imaginations and get them to come and
buy tickets again so I think what's so
cool about Jurassic world and what is so
in the spirit of the original film is is
the is the plausibility of the
circumstances and
and and yet it is kind of this like
really in its essence this this very
faithful what-if sci-fi journey and you
know and there's big dinosaur so that
big dinosaurs and you mentioned the
what-if in the John Hammonds dream part
of this wish fulfillment is that the
park is open this one those four words
and so if the park were open and you got
a chance to go to the park is there a
particular attraction this movie has so
many incredible things at sites inside
of it was there an attraction that you
would want to visit okay so I have two
answers for that so one if there was a
real dinosaur park that opened I would
never get anywhere near it because I've
seen the movies so I know what happens
if you go to a dinosaur park that being
said if we're just imagining I think
definitely the exhibit that I would want
to see the most would be the petting zoo
my son actually got to be an extra in
the petting zoo scene and he got to hug
the neck of a baby dinosaur and that was
awesome well there's so much for
audiences to experience with this movie
and there's so many emotions all
throughout it it's pure big-screen magic
what do you hope audiences feel when
they watch this movie I mean I really
what I hope whether or not it's possible
I mean I've we've been hearing just
great things about the movie which is
awesome in such a relief in so many ways
I think that I think that that what I
want is for people to experience what I
experienced when I went to the theaters
install a drastic park I mean I want for
people to take their families and their
friends and meet up and and go see
jurassic world in 3d or an IMAX and have
a blast and go on a ride and have a
really memorable experience together I
mean that's what it comes down to it's
good story well told and hopefully
creating a you know in the process of
memory so you know that's that's what I
want
you